joining me now missouri senator
josh hawley are you going to be there
senator
no i'm going to be watching from home
jesse like the rest of america and uh i
imagine it's going to be quite the piece
of theater as he tries to explain his
terrible record so what do you think is
going to happen tonight is he going to
address
anything how to reduce gas prices is he
going to hammer the russian energy
sector
what do you expect him to say
what i expect is a lot of smoke and
mirrors taking credit for things he's
had nothing to do with while trying to
distract attention from his dumpster
fire of a presidency i mean listen what
he should be saying is we need to open
up american energy production full
throttle we need to be the energy
dominant nation in the world and we're
not and the reason we're not is joe
biden the reason we have runaway
inflation is joe biden the reason we
have a shipping crisis a supply chain
crisis at this stage is joe biden so if
he wants to
assign blame all he needs is a mirror
and he can look in it because he's the
source of most of these problems and the
solutions he's offering are either
non-existent or totally fake well you
know your colleagues pretty well are
they going to stand up and give him a
round of applause when he talks about
you know forming this coalition to take
on putin and and rallying the free world
or are they going to sit on their hands
you know i don't know why this
administration is breaking its arm
patting itself on the back for an
invasion that it didn't prevent the goal
should have been to deter vladimir putin
from invading a sovereign nation he
utterly failed in that regard we have an
invasion on our hands and part of the
big reason for that is joe biden gave
energy dominance to vladimir putin he
shut down our pipeline and he opened up
russia's pipeline that's the biden
legacy that's what he's done so now it's
time to change course and if the
president wants to be serious he'll
admit that his policies have been wrong
that his policies have been weak that
his policies have endangered this nation
and the world and he'll tell us how he's
going to change course all right i don't
expect that but i will be watching
anyway thank you so much senator hawley
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else